how are you guys doing I'm joined with a
very very special guest um who's very
famous in the Arab world and who's also
uh getting involved in things in the
English world as brother ham how are you
doing I'm good brother ham is a Muslim
filmmaker and YouTuber podcaster uh very
very uh well respected in the Arab world
what we're going to be doing today is I
want you to me and you uh we're both
from Egypt from the Arab world and we're
both Muslim people and we're both
reacting to this uh situation in
Palestine Y and we're both very affected
by it um but I saw something of Joe
Rogan you know who Joan is definely um I
saw something which made me respect him
a little bit a little bit more okay and
I wanted to show it to you and then we
can react to it together let's do it
okay so if you're a Palestinian and you
live in Gaza you're just you're just
stuck you're stuck forever and that's
why these people are like people from
America they're like why you know that's
why you have this Mantra like oh they
want to die they raised their kids to be
suicide bombers no when you're in Gaza
you are born dead
you don't have a life so that's why
these people are giving up their lives
to send a message to us that's why
they're doing this that's the only
reason they're doing this is to send a
message to us help us that's all they
can do is use their
bodies it's just terrifying to me forget
about whether it's Israel or Palestine
forget about what it is the idea that
people could be stuck born stuck in this
spot and really have no recourse and no
nowhere to go and just be thought of by
by people that live just a few miles
away from you you're subhuman and that
the fact that someone can make that
T-shirt with one bullet two kills and
show a pregnant woman with crosshairs on
her belly that scares the out of
me so what do you what do you think of
that I don't know man I'm I'm I'm used
to asking questions so uh like what
happened to you for example on pier
Morgan and stuff and you talking about
Ben Shapiro and you like you you've
talked to Jordan Peterson and stuff so I
think uh the issue is uh we we get
caught up on uh what these people say
and we're almost kind of looking for
them to give us kind of approval or uh
you know yeah yeah so I know what he
says is kind of like it it yeah it I
mean it does make sense yeah uh but it's
it's kind of sugarcoated a little bit
you know like Ben Shapiro is like okay
we listen to him it makes sense when he
talks about LGBT and all that stuff it's
like okay this guy says what I want to
say but at the same time he's like kill
these you know we have to kill as much
and stuff so I'm I'm trying to figure
out what the balance should be uh of of
listening to these people like for
example Jordan Peterson I was with a
good friend of mine and he started
listening to him and the series that he
makes about the Bible the biblical stuff
and he's now a Christian because of him
right
so I don't know it's uh I'm not waiting
for this kind of
approval although I am happy that I I'm
happy for him but it doesn't affect me
like it it it doesn't it shouldn't even
make me happy do you know one one thing
is there's there's a famous saying I
don't know who said it but it's a very
famous saying it says that if you want
to know who rules over you look at who
you can't
criticize and we've seen a lot of people
in the right wing we've seen obviously
Ben shapur's uh invested Jordan Peterson
you mentioned who's recently just been
coming out and uh attacking the cause
and and calling effectively nah to give
them hell or whatever it is which
entails the killing of civilians
effectively and we've seen other people
even Pi Morgan who have been in the show
have a very strong bias towards uh
Palestine um against Palestine and for
Israel we've seen these kinds of things
and in this in the context of all that
this sounds much much much better like
for example he mentioned subhuman right
so he's he's
he is alluding to the fact that there's
dehumanization going on in Israel he is
alluding to the fact that what's going
there is not favorable conditions he
isn't taking a strong Pro Israeli style
uh stance which in my view is so much
better than his
compatriots however as you mentioned is
sugara the bit and I agree fully with
your sentiment it's a really it's an
excellent uh
point but it shows us who's controlled
and who's not and this is not just for
the Muslim Community right
but people have seen even with Piers
Morgan and Jordan Peterson what i' I've
been analyzing their their comment
sections I've been analyzing everything
what I found is that it seems to me that
it's not just within the Muslim
Community people outside of the Muslim
Community are now considered them to be
Hypocrites and people that are
effectively being paid to say what
they're saying and that is so
dishonorable for them it's so it's the
worst thing they could potentially be
marred with I think because
if if you think about what they preach
truth journalism honesty transparency 12
rules whatever it may be speak the truth
even if it's not expedient whatever it
may be this flies in the face of all of
that doesn't it and so I I like the idea
that this is sugar coating we're not
waiting for the
approval but do you think that sometimes
giving these people a little bit of
incentive for for being brave
effectively for saying something which
they know that it's going to get them um
back lash with certain members of the
community is something we Muslims could
do
strategically um I think so um I think
uh like I told you I I could be like
good for him right but but at the same
time when he was speaking he's like like
regardless of it being like like he
tried to distance it from being yes that
kind of issue like Palestinian and stuff
so it again it's it's not what I'm
trying to it's not the same thing right
for us it's not even about land right
for us it's a religious cause it's not
just about like these are you know
Invaders or or anything right like so so
I I know what you're trying to say is
and the part about him being being able
to say what he wants like that's what I
wanted to ask you maybe
about um you you you come from Egypt so
you kind of think that uh well I'm going
to Canada or UK or whatever so I can say
what I want right but then you come here
and then during big events like you know
the the parades of the against the LGBT
and stuff that happened here in Canada
like the the very big organizations here
in Canada weren't uh you know weren't
pushing for it we're promoting it right
so the question of is freedom of speech
actually a thing that's a beautiful
question and that's something someone
like Joe Rogan who's been speaking about
it for very many years and people on the
right wing they should be answering this
question cuz a lot of them have been
jumping on the bandwagon and saying that
the waving of Palestinian flags and
protests should be illegal we're seeing
people now I've been communicating with
people here in Canada and people in UK
and all over the West saying that
they're finding problems at work they're
finding problems at work and in
different places because they have they'
have been noticed by their employers to
be Pro Palestinian and they're
connecting that with terrorism all kinds
of things it's the first time in history
in my life that I've ever seen such uh
difficulties and complications that
people are facing because of activism of
a pro Palestinian kind so much so that
we're considering starting some kind of
name and shame organization to see which
organizations are actually attacking
Muslim people or Pro Palestinian people
in this way and for us to name and shame
them and this might be an action that we
take but the point is there is a huge
hypocrisy here the rightwing which is
it's whole Mantra is freedom of speech
and expression is effectively large
suedes of it telling us no you can't do
this this kind of protest you can't wave
that kind of flag uh you should stop
this and it's unbelievable who's coming
from um but because time is of the
essence I really have uh enjoyed your
your uh contribution and what is your uh
YouTube channel for someone who wants to
check it out uh you could just uh type
in h h a z e mik beautiful and it's
English and Arabic you got stuff in both
languages yeah yeah alhamdulillah I'm
sure people would want to hear your
insights and you've got some fantastic
interview there also also a podcast
called why why yeah it's in Arabic it's
about myself and two other brothers we
talk about religion in a very casual
manner uh hamul one of the best not best
but it's you know it's kind of uh it's
kind of big in the Middle
East perfect well thank you so much than
for the opportunity time and make sure
guys that you subscribe to his channel
and you keep at it with the pr War
because we and the public opinion
perspective right now are in an
unprecedented place where we're pushing
and the people are seeing the fake news
people are seeing this is nonsense
people say people are being paid to
support Zionism and the voice of the
Muslims now everyone's watching us we
collectively have a massive
responsibility please let's take this uh
opportunity to to spread our message and
to strengthen our ranks and to be United
as
Muslims and come together on goodness
and
righteousness